so gentlemen moving on though this is
now
our last few moments in the studio
yeah yeah this is this this is the last
episode of
season one i guess i guess it is if it's
gonna come out
i don't know if we're doing like season
one via studios or via the year
um i mean either way this is the end
right because i think
we're like right on as we're recording
this is like one year anniversary i'm
pretty sure
i'm pretty sure i don't know something
right so 53 right yeah
yeah yeah 53 or 50 close enough oh
that's 52 weeks in a year and
uh and the one over here yeah yeah yeah
of course
yeah wow i mean it felt a lot longer
than a year to be honest
i don't remember the studio being this
full you know i don't remember
i don't remember what it looked like
before it's scary going back to like
episode one yeah
and being like it doesn't look like the
same room i'll tell you what
after you mentioned it on the trash
taste awards i remember looking at the
first episode again as well and i forgot
that
we originally had our camera all the way
back there
yeah so it kind of looked like you were
peeking through like like you know
you're peeking through being like oh
what are they getting onto now it just
feels like way too close hello this
is the new camera angle that we changed
to you know
well like 30 episodes ago yeah just it
just feels it just feels weird i forgot
that we changed camera angles and the
different feeling that they gave off
um and yeah like i'm impressed how many
guests we got this year as well
that's uh yeah given the limited
circumstances of all nine of them
yeah uh but yeah i'm sure chris will be
on again yeah
of course no man i'm sure chris is going
to come knocking on this
is he going to be the first guest on in
season two as well he said he wants to
be
just asserting dominance to every other
guest i don't see why not i didn't ask
what else is there to talk about with
chris
what do you mean just have chris on each
insanity and shoes
chris chris just makes funny moments by
being on your bully chris chris bully's
ours you know it's a good deal
looking forward to what drip he's gonna
be wearing next after after winning
laziest drip in season
season one you know like after that
episode goes on he's going to be like
i gotta come with like a suit i told
chris i was like you won an award by the
way
he's like you want two awards no no no
he said and i was like oh yeah
you're one of the awards i really really
was like yeah yeah just one
i was like [ __ ] off chris
or lucky for you chris i didn't tell him
about the second one sorry surprise
yeah but i guess uh yeah i guess by the
time you see us next week
we'll be in a hopefully brand new setup
yeah it'll be like a month for us it'll
be like
one week for you guys yeah sweet for you
guys yeah we want to remodel and uh
change the setup a little bit and get
the angles down we're not gonna have
like a completely different setup right
off the bat i think it's it's gonna be
similar to season one where we
kind of grow our set as the season goes
on you know i i feel i i like
well you haven't decided everything yet
but we have no idea what the new set is
going to look like i want to get
all new figures that's what i want that
get rid of that involves having
another akihabara special which is going
to be pretty hard
right now considering yeah everything is
locked down
so maybe you'll have to wait a little
bit longer compared to season one to get
a new akihabara special
um but we do want to do one in the
future um
apart from that i don't know what other
plans i'm i'm i'm just excited to show
you guys
like at the new set though yeah and
having a proper trash taste office not
just
an apartment that we just remodeled into
a set i mean you'll get you guys will
see it in the after dark vlog i mean
like speaking of like there'll be way
more after
content as well yeah we're gonna have
two sets now so the after dark specials
aren't just going to be trash taste 1.5
yeah oh yeah i mean that's the main i
think that's one of the big reasons why
we want to move is just to
allow us to make more yeah more content
because right now it's you know i mean
you can make content in this room i'm
sure we could but
it's one of those things where but at
what cost well yeah you're in a room
that you just
despise yeah it's too cramped you don't
want to make
like stuff you don't feel creative you
don't feel like you want to do anything
like you guys will see when we vlog it
but like behind the set is an absolute
mess and actually i mean the set is a
mess yeah the entire room is the entire
place is a mess
the beauty of camera angles is
everything looks bigger but this is
it is not as neat as you think it is in
fact like i get
actually like physically embarrassed
whenever a guest comes oh yeah that's
pretty embarrassing
yeah because the one thing the one
mutual thing that every guest says is
wow this place is a lot smaller than it
looks
like yeah we know we know it's it's like
you know when your mom comes in and your
room isn't tidy that's what i feel like
you know
the first thing i feel like saying is
apologizing and then the second thing is
like
whoever has to explain to the guests
that they're going to be sitting here
and the first thing you have to explain
to them is how to get here and you're
just like
oh you just gotta go around the set i
think like you cannot see
any of the desk and we have three desks
over there yeah at the wall you can't
see any of the desk
my desk is a [ __ ] war zone that
meleen's turned into which would you
which was the guest
that thought you had to go under again
who was that reyna
oh yeah right yeah i think it was great
enough there was so little space
reynolds
literally thought that you had to go
under the table are they honestly
there's probably more room under the
table yeah honestly probably
i can't believe there's less of a trippy
hazard under here i can't fault her for
thinking that honestly
yeah everything every the way we've done
it is all it works but it's
literally the meme of like the cheeto
holding the door along yeah yeah
yeah like everything works but it's not
clean
it can be about like it looks good i'm
happy with how it look considering what
we've done it's the most scuffed way we
can of it
looking as good as it sounding as good
as it does but yeah we wanna we already
want to upgrade it and
i don't know get get a better system in
general just for everything have more
guests on you know have guests on after
dark
you know just having everything upgraded
everything better you know and uh
you know it's because of you guys that
we're even able to [ __ ] move toward
you know yeah yeah yeah yeah without the
patreon stuff we would definitely
be able to consider the upgrades that
we're doing absolutely basically when we
started this podcast
we were just like what's the minimum we
can get away with in case
this podcast is like zero crashes just
crashes and burns immediately
yeah so we planned this on like as much
of a budget as much money as we were
willing to put in
yeah essentially yeah how much money do
we want to lose and then also hours do
we want to lose
yeah exactly yeah exactly but like yeah
i mean again like we said this in the
previous episode with the the trash
taste
awards obviously but we're very we're
very grateful i think for the
crazy amount of support i think if you'd
have told us that we'd be this close to
a million subs after one year i think
we'd have been like
funny 100 000 subs that's a success
because we only we only pushed this
channel like once
twice on our main channels yeah once in
a at the end of the start of a video or
end of a video and then
the happy and then the icarus especially
considering it's everything else is
driven by like twitter and you guys just
enjoying the show yeah
you guys spreading the good word it's uh
it's crazy man it's crazy to see it and
it's like because normally
with a lot of podcasts i see you have
like with big names in them you have
like the big announcements so you've got
the big trickle of views
yeah and then the view the view just
like drips down which is what i was
expecting and i wasn't expecting us to
maintain like
the view count yeah for 50 episodes
it's also intimidating because now i
know that the stuff is the dumb [ __ ] i
say will be in front of more people than
ever
yeah one thing i certainly was surprised
by was just
like just realizing that some of the
[ __ ] we say to each other people
like hundreds of thousands of people are
now listening to you yeah
i forget about everything i [ __ ] say
like i said all the dumb [ __ ] like i got
an email today about baked beans
about one of the semi-baked beans i
totally forgot i said i like baked beans
and someone's offering to send me a ton
of baked beans and i'm like i'm
flattered
you can't say no to that i just can't
remember
why i said this i i've totally think
about this
just sounds like a random person wanting
to sing beans i know i went on the rant
about loving baked beans
but that was one of those things where
i'm very passionate at the moment and
then when i when i leave i totally
forget that i
had a rant about it exactly yeah i did i
did talk very passionately about baked
beans that is me
i feel that's a lot of moments right i
mean sometimes you just get passionate
when you're talking with your mates or
when you're in like a [ __ ]
is it kaya or having like an argument
where it's not really an argument and
you're just
you're just very passionate in the
moment you reckon we'll get any comments
people like men
i like the old set more there's a better
vibe to it well the table's gonna be the
same
i stopped watching after season one
season one is when it went downhill yeah
two is a real
i mean essentially it's not too much is
going to change really
really okay two to two to like bring
down expectations really the reason we
want to change
um change offices is because this is not
a convenient office
at all um on camera we don't want too
much to change
uh we just want to work more comfortably
instead of having this like the most
jank [ __ ] setup for everything we do
i mean
right now trash tastes after dark is
running off of my laptop
okay there's probably three giant ass
hdmis going into this man's laptop yeah
the cable management
is atrocious literally literally it's
like it's a laptop that's sitting
um that's like hooked up on a like on a
foldable chair
that's like that's like connected with
wide internet that's just running in the
middle of the floor
that's that's it that's that's trash
tastes awesome it is jank is fun that's
because we can't afford more space
right now so that it's like the most
junk
it's mostly for us enough of us
complaining about
our problems i guess uh everything
should hopefully
be better we don't know because we
haven't moved yet but we're hoping that
everything goes really
smoothly offset i want to shout out to
the denny's guy
you're the real dude the denny's guy is
always there for us
we've talked before about boss man's
always waiting for us yeah
we've talked before about how ev every
every time four trash chase recording we
have lunch at denny's and we've gone
there so often that
there's a guy at denny's who knows the
exact time we're coming in
on the exact day and he he knows he
knows what we want we ordered the same
thing every time he knows how many
people as well
i've not i've not met a boss man in
japan
and yeah i hadn't met a boss man in
japan until i met that guy
you're a boss man he's real boss man
he's the i love it because like
sometimes we would come into the danny's
yeah and he would just the moment he
sees us he's like hey oh okay
it's like four right yeah i got you i
got you i've got a reserved for you
don't worry you're gonna miss the milf
bar that's also
like next door as well so we we just we
discovered we discovered a bar
a restaurant just it's it's just it's
just a woman yeah it's just a
woman it's just a restaurant that's just
run by attractive
older japanese single mills and i
remember i remember
conor first going into there and it's
kind of like and he had an awakening
i was like the problem because it's a
new bar
and then we almost we came back almost
every week for a while the land of milk
and honey
is right around the corner what a
beautiful bar
yeah i'm going to miss this area as well
like it's like you know i didn't have
much expectations for this area
obviously
because we're in a quiet area yeah but
like you know we've come so
after a year we've come to appreciate
the small things you know
we could say we're inside i'm all right
it's whatever sure we can say we're
inside yeah
sure okay i don't know i mean i don't
think it matters now we're not we're not
we're not there anymore yeah yeah we're
going guys again we're not there anymore
so we we were inside dumber but not
anymore
commuting was a pain in the ass exactly
again everything was on a budget side to
my eyes
outside of tokyo it's like an hour it's
like an hour away from tokyo it's
immediately cheap
just just close enough that it kind of
feels like it's in tokyo
yeah kind of like being in zone four
zone five in london right yeah it's like
tell your you know
love to be like yeah so the studios at
uh heathrow airport just uh
it wasn't it wasn't that far it wasn't
that well heathrow airport's like an
hour of
power from central london yeah but tokyo
is a lot bigger as well though i mean
you can go from one end of tokyo to yo
to young
another in an hour as well so i
understand these references
[Laughter]
heathrow yes downtown manhattan right
i'm sure i don't
i guess thank you for watching thank you
for watching season one yeah
you have much else to say really yeah i
hope you guys stick with us
all through season two look forward to
more fun epic
i mean there probably won't be a season
thing i don't think we plan on uh
upgrading from the new studios
yeah it'll be it'll be season two for a
while
season one is the test run yeah season
two is the one that has like 500
episodes
okay don't don't think there's going to
be many new plot developments
yeah this is literally it this is like
season one was like the 54 episode pilot
season two is where the actual show
begins
but uh yeah hopefully uh you guys enjoy
the new studio yeah
it's just like arthur does arthur have
seasons i don't know if arthur has
arthur
arthur oh you mean the the show the
cartoon
yeah does that have seasons does arthur
have seasons i feel like it's just
running
we're like we're gonna be
i've never heard of anyone being like uh
season 23 of arthur was my favorite
does arthur have seasons can you google
it arthur doesn't have season it just
runs it just keeps going
i say it's more like come dine with me
all right we're just gonna keep coming
and coming every week we come every week
guys trash days comes every week calm
now